When we first open up the Miwok app,
we see this list of categories.
Now, there's only a couple of categories
here, and this list is pretty fixed.
So in this case,
we can stick with using a vertical
linear layout with four text views.
Now on the other hand,
when I tap into the Numbers activity,
these list items could
get more complicated.
We could potentially add a lot more
vocabulary words to this list.
For example, deciding to display
the numbers 1 through 1,000.
So this list is a good use case for
viewer cycling.
So I'm going to show you
how to modify our code so
that we can use the list view and
array adapter.
Now, I know there's a lot of concepts
going on right now but it's okay.
We'll take it one step at a time.
First, I'd like you to get the code
working and running on your phone.
And then I want you to make some
observations on how you think it's all
working together.
And then afterwards,
we'll walk through together what's
exactly happening behind the scenes.